بعد تويتر
وامازون باتت جوجل احدث الشركات
التكنولوجيه العملاقه التي تسرح العمال
فيوفقا للشركه الام لجوجل الفابيت قامت
جوجل بالغاء حوالي 12 الف وظيفه ما يمثل
اكثر من 6% من موظفيها عالميه وهو القرار
الذي قال الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعه الفا
بيت انه يتحمل مسؤوليته بالكامل تاثير هذه
التغييرات على حياه موظفي جوجل يلقي بثقله
عليه وانا اتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله عن
القرارات التي ادت بنا الى هنا
بفضل تماسك النشاط البحث كانت جوجل واحده
من شركات التكنولوجيا التي تمكنت من تجنب
اجراء تخفيضات كبيره في قوتها العامله
لفتره طويله في اكتوبر 2022 انخفضت ارباح
جوجل الى 27% حوالي 14 مليار دولار مقارنه
بالعام السابق كما خفضت اسهمها بنحو 30
بالمئه وهو الامر الذي دفع المستثمرين
لاجبار الشركه الرائده على تبني
استراتيجيه اكثر صرامه للحد من الانفاق
قطاع التكنولوجيا يشهد طابات عن اقتصاديا
كبيرا ما ترك الموظفين العاملين في هذا
القطاع في حاله عدم اليقين والقلق على
مستقبلهم
قطاع التكنولوجيا يشهد طبع اقتصاديا كبيرا
ما ترك الموظفين العاملين في هذا القطاع
في حاله عدم اليقين والقلق على مستقبلهم